Fixing up a car to drive in it again,...
...searching for the water, hoping for the rain...
...up and up,...
...up and up.
Down upon the canvas, working meal to meal,...
...waiting for a chance to pick your orange field,...
...up and up,...
...up and up.
See a pearl form a diamond in the rough,...
...see a bird soaring high above the flood.
It's in your blood,...
...it's in your blood.
Underneath the storm an umbrella is saying,...
..."Sitting with the poison takes away the pain."
Up and up,...
...up and up.
It's saying we're gonna get it, get it together right now,...
...gonna get it, get it together somehow.
We're gonna get it, get it together and flower.
We're gonna get it, get it together I know.
We're gonna get it, get it together and flow.
We're gonna get it, get it together and go...
...up and up and up.